what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight update video I didn't plan on
releasing another video so soon but some
very interesting and exciting news just
came out thanks to Watchers on the wall
I honestly don't even know where to
begin but I think you will be very
excited to hear this there haven't been
too many spoilers this season but what
I'm about to tell you could have some
major implications for what can possibly
happen in the final season Game of
Thrones recently started to film again
and according to the sources from
Watchers on the wall we will be seeing a
few scenes in the crypts of Winterfell
apparently we will be seeing the crypts
of Winterfell and at least two episodes
this season and it's looking like we
will see them in the first two episodes
in season 8 their source tells them that
two main characters will be seen
discussing Ned's death down there I have
a feeling one of those main characters
will be Jon Snow we know Jon is heading
home and brain is about to drop a
bombshell on him when Jon finds out Ned
is not his father he's gonna be shocked
and very confused and I think Jon's
gonna want to go down into the crypts to
see Ned and his mother Liana the other
main character that could be with him is
anyone's guess it could be brand that
goes down there with him or even Oreo
but I think pretty much any of the
Starks would be a good guess Samwell
Tarly is there as well and I'm sure he's
gonna want to tell John about the
annulment that Rhaegar had not to
mention some of the things that he's
been learning while he was at the
Citadel I will be honest though this
spoiler does not surprise me that much
to be fair it only says two main
characters go down there it doesn't say
who but I know Jon will be going down
there once again when he finds out who
his parents actually are and since Jon
hasn't seen Arya and bran in a very long
time I imagine he will spend as much
time as he possibly can with them
especially with Bryan considering they
will devise a plan together to stop the
night king but there is another spoiler
I want to talk about because this is the
one that got me very excited according
to this source at the end of this scene
someone will be blowing a horn that's
right it says their scene ends with a
horn being blown keep in mind this isn't
at the wall this was on location where
they film in the crypts of Winterfell so
I don't think this is the whole
the Nights Watch uses if this isn't the
horn they blow on the wall there are
only two other horns that I can really
think of which is the dragon horn and
the Horn of winter now we haven't seen
the dragon horn yet but we did see a
horn north of the wall when Sam found
the cache of dragonglass
but we haven't seen the horn since in
the books
Sam takes this horn with them to the
citadel and there is a good chance Sam
has always had this horn with him in the
show Sam also stole all kinds of books
and documents from the Citadel - and
there is also a good chance he may find
out what this horn is actually used for
brain star can also find this out - all
we would need to do is plug into the
weirwood net to find out if Watchers on
the walls report is correct the scenes
with the crypts and the horn will be
featured in one of the episodes that is
directed by Miguel supports Nic which is
the director best known for filming some
of Game of Thrones greatest battles now
when you put all of this together there
are several different things that
immediately come to mind but it all
depends on which horn they are actually
blowing I'm really not sure if we're
gonna see the dragon horn but if we did
they could use it to try and bring down
Vasari on I don't really know how that
would work since it's a dragon that was
raised by the knight king but it
probably wouldn't hurt to try but I
think it will be the Horn of winter
since we have seen that horn already
according to legend this horn is capable
of bringing down the wall and waking
Giants but we have already seen both of
those things the wall is down and we
have seen living giants and dead Giants
but if this horn is blown in the crypts
of Winterfell you have to wonder if it
has anything to do with all of those
stone kings down there there have been
several hints about these kings possibly
waking up and a horn may just be the
thing to do this I know this may sound
like crazy 10 foil to some of you but
what this being the last season I am
expecting just about anything to happen
I think this horn most likely has
something to do with defeating the White
Walkers this horn was found with
dragonglass which is another weapon that
defeats the White Walkers so why would
someone put that horn there with that
unless it would help them - I made a
video a long time ago and I said what if
the Horn of winter is sort of like a
dragon horn but instead of it
controlling a dragon
what if it could control the night
king's army what if the Horn of winter
is like a dog whistle and it can get the
army of the Dead to stop right in their
tracks I'm gonna start to work on
another video about some of these things
so I will save some of my speculation
for the next one but let me know what
you think about this news I will put the
link down in the description that way
you can read the report for yourself
it's pretty damn interesting don't
forget to check out the other video that
I uploaded today as well it's not really
as exciting as this one but it has
another spoiler about what the first
scene in season 8 will be either way
thanks for stopping by to watching this
video I really do appreciate that
and I also want to thank my patreon
supporters have a great day everyone
I will see you in the next one bye
[Music]